hello everybody hope they are good
Bitcoin is good Bitcoin is at
47,4 right now you almost got to 50%
Weck Target at
48,000 and yes I think it's going to get
there because there is no reason for
Bitcoin to top up here right before
reaching that okay so um I think it has
a bit of f left not going to lie I think
it's going to go at least to the 50% of
the week 48,000 with the possibility to
reach a 100% of the week a 49,000 so
we're going to talk about this um idea
during this video and also of course my
my high time frame view because so far
it's playing out and I gu made a post on
Twitter and some people agreed some
people disagree so uh I'm not here for
you to agree or disagree I'm only
telling you my opinion what it can
happen and the moment maybe I'm wrong
but the moment that you say it's
impossible then I know you're you're
wrong because in crypto everything is
possible okay so um thank you so much
for watching uh the videos this week I'm
really enjoying making the the videos
because it's a very good way for me to
express what is in my mind better than
with text it works better for me I think
so thank you for watching the videos in
yesterday's video we were talking about
the idea that Bitcoin was working its
way towards this liquidity pool that by
the way now has been um fully retraced
so I'm going I remove it from my chart
you can see that it fully got fully
retraced and we were also talking of
course about the week that it could get
there and also a little warning that
this scenario could be validated only if
we saw the daily candle this daily
candle stick here from yesterday closing
back below the range SI we were saying
that this wasn't likely to happen
because so far we were testing the range
SI as support in the 4 hours time frame
you can see here let's go there you know
you can see here perfectly how we were
testing our support but it was good to
keep an eye on this because if that
happened then that would basically tell
you that this pent was a fake out out
and we're want to go to the range lows
by the way what would form a long
position all the way to the week because
that week needs to get filled the
Candlestick closed above the range size
perfect and to me that was the moment
that I said okay you know what I missed
this move here because I was waiting for
a new retest of the 8 hours uh 50 ma
didn't get quite there that was a bit of
a fail for me so I missed these scandles
here but yesterday as soon as as we
close the daily candles stick above the
range SI that's when I open a a quick uh
long position um yeah I'm targeting the
50% of the week at the 50% of the week
I'm going to I'm going to take profits
80% of my position and then the other
20% is going to go to the 100% of the
week and of course and traing my stops
okay right now it's around here
45,600 I think it is so it's basically
around here right um so let's see how
that plays out so far good but it could
have been a lot better not going to lie
it was a bit of a feel I didn't catch
that the entry uh but anyway now how do
I know if Bitcoin is going to get to the
100% of the week or not what's the thing
with the week well I'm going to give a a
brief explanation cuz of course all the
explanation is in the course but um
basically when uh weeks are imbalances
DEC create imbalances in several ways uh
in open interest gaps um or that have
even been triggered because it's a fast
move okay so Wick needs to get filled
because that's where the liquidity is
and the market makes the money the
exchanges in the market maker makes the
money from commissions okay so if a Weck
or a liquidity pool is an imbalance that
the gathers liquidity then it's
convenient for the market to go there
okay so this should get filled now if
you gets to the 50% of the week I've
noticed that uh sometimes you can see
reactions at the 50% of the week
okay and that would mean that the week
is fully filled it doesn't need to go to
the 100% just as so far as long as it
goes at least to the 50% of the week
then it's failed now at the 50% of the
week you have to be careful because we
might see a rejection that's what I'm
taking most of my profits there however
if we start to see some um consolidation
I would say yeah some kind of sideways
around the 50% of of the week without a
reaction without a rejection to the
downside then that is telling you that
price is going to go towards the 100%
okay and if you notice that's a $1,000
move which means that you mean if you um
are going to take profits now or you
haven't caught that this move you still
have that opportunity okay just watch if
Bitcoin goes to the 50% of the week and
doesn't drop and it stays there for a
few hours that is going to tell you okay
there is a massive chance Bitcoin does
another $1,000 move up toward the 100%
of the week so keep an eye on that move
okay because that's a very good sculp um
and and and basically Can it can it can
be very beneficial for for for Traders
to take that trade in my opinion and
that's a trade I'm going to I'm going to
take even if I TP um most of my position
at the 50% of the week if I start to see
the behavior of consolidation of the 50%
of the week then I'll open a new long
I'll add to my long and and have another
big TP at the 100% of the week so that's
a that's a setup that I'm keeping an eye
on even if the the move is very very
extended and is dangerous to Long these
moves of course also is dangerous to
short them we now to have Capital to see
what happened but um I know that I
usually don't long when I see so many
green candles but I can tell you that
this is a move that I've been watching
for quite long time and I'm quite
confident longing this myself if I see
consolidation at the 50% of the week
okay so um that's one trading setup that
you can keep an eye on for the next few
days or even today if we get there boom
um in terms of uh already positioned
Longs then um it's not Financial advice
of course but myself 50% of the week and
100% of the week are my my take profits
I want to take you to high block Capital
guys because uh I want to show you
something that I found very interesting
this morning and gave me an idea that
price was going to continue moving
higher but if you guys remember we've
been talking about this liquidity
between
43,600 and
44,600 we've been talking about this
liquidity for the last few days um with
the idea that this liquidity was going
to get was going to um was going to be
taken okay uh now you can see how the
liquidity uh how that those liquidations
were hit and yesterday you could see a
bit of liquidity around 47,000 but not
much okay but it was starting to for so
liquidity up there and then the market
maker decided to push price higher and
you can see how the Liquidations in the
area
47,000 become bigger you can see this
those green bars turn into yellow bars
because the liquidity increases there
okay the question is why and it's
basically because as price goes up and
it's being quite over extended then the
M then the retail Trader thinks oh look
at this LSI indicator it says overb I'm
going to short or look at this uh I
don't know Max CD or you know some kind
of uh indicator especially RSI RSI gets
a lot of people um uh wrecked so I don't
recommend
ssis when it tells you overbought that's
when usually you see this a spike up or
when it tells you over sold that's
usually when you see price really going
down so be careful with careful with the
indicator because I have a feeling that
that's what happen happened here okay at
47,000 that's where retail traded was
starting to do short around here the uh
liquidations increased and you can see
how the market maker didn't think twice
he just took that liquidity okay so now
if you go again into the 70 time frame
let me update this I don't see much
liquidity to the upside starting to form
at
51,000 but uh it's a very long way still
okay it's another pretty much 10% up so
um not really close not really
interesting so of at the moment at least
now in the one month time
frame we that we don't see much we can
see that there was some liquidations
here at 47,000 to uh they will take it
and nothing else okay so in the
liquidation
levels this chart is going to give us a
better idea now I have to change the
settings in here
okay take the settings with a pinch of
salt uh the numbers I mean because uh
they are not real so take them as a
reference only running out it says that
there are $23 billion worth of long
liquidations okay the market is heavily
position into Longs nobody wants to
short right now cuz the why is that have
short they got liquidated okay that's
what the liquidation hit map say so
there are no many Traders uh going short
right now uh you can see here the really
um only one out of eight Traders are
going short so the market is at the
moment quite Vias okay uh now that's
that's to me this is a sign of concern
it should over the weekend we're want to
probably see some consolidation and
that's going to make this um Delta
cooling off okay and it's going to get a
bit more neutral but at the moment it's
at 23 billion dollar that's a lot I want
to see how this number is on Monday
because usually between 20 and 30
billion I that's when we see reversals
okay if today was Tuesday and not Friday
and the weekend was was not in front of
us if it was Tuesday I would tell you
it's time to look for shorts right now
okay because there is going to be a
reversal at any time but with the
weekend in front of us that I know it's
going to be some consolidation the Del
is going to co off then let's see let's
pick let's pick this up on Monday okay
now this is Pikes at the right what do
they mean they are basically liquidation
points
you can see of course more spikes to the
downside because there are many Longs
open at the moment okay but you can also
see some uh a couple of spikes to the
upside okay and if momentum is not
sifting so far at the moment then why
not why why they not going to take this
liquidity so we have one Spike at
48080 that is basically the 50% of the
week and the other one is exactly at
29 at the 100% of the week that's your
two levels guys so keep an eye on these
levels because if we get here um to
these levels today I think there is a
big chance that that's going to be the
local top okay fill the week uh unless
if it leaves a new imbalance to the
upside but if it fills the week then we
could look next week to take some shorts
all right so um that's what I I would
tell you I would ensure at the moment
cuz I I think the week needs to get
filled first if it drops from here and
that's the local top I'll be extremely
surprised I think it's highly unlikely I
think it makes more sense to First fill
that week at least partially the 50%
perhaps the 100% or even sweep the highs
so 48 49k first then we're want to see
how the chart is looking how the
liquidations are looking okay if there
is acceptance about 49k then yes we can
continue going higher but if that's not
the case then that is going to be a
reversal level okay so we're going to
talk more about this on Monday uh I'm
not going to post any videos over the
weekend the daily videos are Monday to
Friday but uh over the weekend I'm also
going to be looking at Al coins to too
long um
so I would recommend you to join the
telegram channel it's free um that's
where I usually post my altcoin charts
okay so yeah maybe we eat some popcorns
and the guys in the T on channel
understand that reference of popcorns
and
altcoins um but yeah maybe this weekend
we can eat some C some popcorns because
Bitcoin is going up it needs to
consolidate and once it consolidates
over the weekend then that's when
altcoins can continue going up okay
because the Bitcoin dominance has also
been going up today and that's why
altcoins are not pumping as much as
Bitcoin but yes if Bitcoin consolidates
over the weekend that is when altcoins
can start to to to see upside okay so
keep an eye on the play on channel this
weekend and now I'm going to talk about
the high time frame view now if you go
to the Daily time frame okay um I'm
going to show you my high time frame
view this is my high time frame view
okay and back in the time it seemed a
bit crazy um because uh when we were in
the range flows of 40,000 41,000 that's
when this screenshot is from and they
posted this High time frame view uh it
seemed to be crazy because I was
basically calling for a
15% move up okay and then for a 20 23%
move down so far that 15% move up it's
pretty much completed cuz if you notice
here what I was basically saying here is
that The Bard in a scenario of this
consolidation was still going to take
some more time and first before dropping
down that maybe that's not the case but
in my opinion this AR range and we might
break down from the range okay that's to
me the most likely we'll see what
happens but first I was saying a move up
and if you notice here that is basically
the 50% of the week okay as you can see
the that's already happened then what
I'm expecting is some um
consolidation again possibly lower highs
back in fall back into inside the range
and then H I've made a mess here and
then just drop towards this uh potential
support here 36k all right so kind of
like this this could take another month
but of course it has an invalidation and
it's acceptance above the 100% of the
week 49k so if we start to see something
like this okay price continue pushing
above the uh uh the 100% of the week and
consolidating here that is basically
telling me you know what perhaps they
are actually preparing for a move higher
and now if you go into the weekly time
frame and we go to the
left to be honest uh I don't see much
resistance at 50,000 okay that means
that it's quite likely that it goes
straight away to 60k okay so if you get
to the 50,000 Zone um I don't see much
resistance in this Zone here okay
so hang
on here really the only really
resistance maybe it could
be this level
52,000 okay but notice that between
52,000 and
60,000 in this area here there is really
not much resistance okay so you can also
go into the daily time frame you're want
to see the same so that means that you
know if Bitcoin goes above 49k the next
Target is is 52k and if we get back
Above This level then 60k are on the
core now right so um those are my my
targets to the upsite but I would lie if
I told you that uh that's the scenario
that I'm that I'm um I'm thinking is
going to happen next okay cuz I I do
think that it's most more likely that we
have some kind of Correction towards
this level here okay that's what I'm
anticipating after we fill 100% of the
week then of course a game of
possibilities and I think this is more
more possible but I'm not Maring to this
idea so I'm just watching the chart guys
if this starts to do this behavior I'm
making higher lows then you know I'll
tell you perhaps my high time frame view
is correct we go to the range lows a
little retest and a drop okay and this
would be the moment that I would take a
swing short all right now you're going
to ask me can I sort at the 50% of the
week I mean you can but you have to be
very careful careful because look at the
momentum okay the momentum is not
showing any um any weakness the momentum
is still going it's not sifting all
right so you have to be very careful yes
it's possible that we go to the 50% of
the week we see the rejection okay but
if you enter at the 50% of the week
enter with a very small size then you
can add some size at the 100% of the
week and your average entry will be
around this level here and your uh
invalidation is clear just watch the
chart if we break above 49k okay no I'm
not saying a sweep of the low like this
because that would be varish okay if we
do something like this that's is still
counts us filling the 100% of the week
and droing so no I don't mean a a sweep
of the lows I mean seeing candlesticks
closing above
49k if that happens then you get out
okay because price is more likely to go
continue going up all right but yeah
this is um this is uh the only short
idea that I see in this area Okay a
small short on the 50% of the week in
case it goes to the 50% on drops so you
don't miss that move and more size at
100% of the week to average your entry
okay now if we if there is some uh
acceptance above 49k then you have to
get out because the price is likely to
continue P higher it's as simple as that
all right low risk just you have to keep
your risk management um as a priority
always so I don't want anybody to go to
the 50% of the week shorting with some
50 leverage and big size that doesn't
make any sense that's gambling okay
that's safer small size bigger size keep
an eye for the invalidation okay and
then if your entri is around
here you're not you're not losing much
okay closing here so uh be careful with
that and obviously don't don't set a a
stop loss right above the week don't set
it here okay because then I can tell you
you can do a sweep of theay highs and
then drop and you you don't want that to
happen to you so better if you can watch
the chart and see if there is acceptance
above the 49k level um that's what I
would recommend you to do again not fin
answer advice uh but that's uh that's
what I'm keeping an eye on okay so
that's everything that I wanted to say
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon